jessica jones your character incredibly
strong
you get to kick the crap out of people
on the show i would think there'd be a
danger
if you do that and it's a regular part
of your life where you're hitting people
and they're flying across the room as
part of your job
that you might start to think i can
really do this in real life 100
when you play a character when you play
a character like this for an extended
period of time you start to adopt some
of her personality traits which is good
and bad
um but i start to think that i'm really
strong and i'll throw myself like really
hard into my fight scenes but then i'm
always covered in bruises and their
medic is always being called and there's
like a joke on set that we go through
more ice packs than like any other show
right because i always like i'm getting
a little you just throw yourself into it
oh yeah i go ham yeah what is ham
um heart as a mother
that's my sister taught me that she's
21. okay i'm sorry
you're gonna bleep that out
it's gonna make you think about the
easter ham very differently